[Music]
oklahoma state almost gets 30 from their
bench but how about this moment he comes
off the double screen gets a
iso situation with braun
here's cunningham just nice footwork and
that one bounce
stop and pop defense so well he plays
with his head up
he's got great balance great pace the
defense is ready to attack him but
they've got good space there's the lob
[Applause]
snipped out by likely leads to the run
out for cunningham
cunningham well there's that grace
and fluidity
gabe cunningham rises and rips
boy that's why he's field goal makes
that's usually a good indication that
the ball is moving
cunningham step back three like did he
really have
18 or 22 or now 27.
how about aceman's asmus with that huge
three
getting the ball down low there's a
great job of using the rim on the shot
button right there see that
once he gets that'll be the best name
number combination in college basketball
good back cut with a shot blocker fading
away
not the answer go right through his
chest
here's another turnover could be an easy
two at this end
and a dunk from cade cunningham
gay cunningham does it from three off
the ball screen that is a pro step back
folks you'll see that in an mba arena
here's the drive and an aau teammate of
kate cunningham and mike miles texas
titans
nice pass cunningham
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
cunningham what a finish from
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey
foreign
[Applause]
up
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
hey
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
three